let's remember what we did yesterday if
we started out this guy
do you remember what it's called and
five is yep so very good
what's more generally speaking this is
about this is about modeling nonlinear
relationships here are two quantities
they're related to each other but not
everything is related in a super simple
straight line way you get other things
right so I want us to today just step
back a little bit and take a bit an
overview I get it
let's go back to a m4 for a second
remember this is a straight line when
you see this kind of form and the key by
the way is that you've got an X term and
there's actually an X to the power of
one hiding in there right it's just that
we don't usually write that so that
distinguishes our straight lines this
one from these guys here these are not
linear functions they're quadratic
functions and the key indicator is a
particular number which number is it
it's the fact that things are squared
right so this is to the power of one
this is to the power of two you can have
the squared in a couple of different
spots actually a variety different spots
but these are the two main ways you'll
see it so these guys here are quadratic
functions a bit of a funny thing
quadratic means like when we look at the
algebra but when we think of the shape
that kind of characteristic curve the
shape is called a parabola so just
distinguish between those two when you
say quadratic you're talking about the
algebra when you talking about when you
say parabola you mean what does it look
like okay now I just want to highlight
this guy because we didn't talk about it
at all
we had to look a lot at these guys here
and we tested lots of values and we
plotted the points and then we drew a
picture but sometimes we want to provide
the same equation in a slightly
different form just rearranged a little
bit I'll give you an example of why when
we think about this you know how you got
the M and the B and they mean something
not just
random letters what do they Evan the
Beast signifier M signifies gradient and
B signifies the y-intercept very good
so when the equation is written in this
form and you look at our rabbit example
over here and you look at something like
this so just make this it example when
you look at that you can immediately
know what the gradient is it's going to
be 5 and you can immediately know what
the y-intercept is going to be negative
1 very good
so that's what this form is sort of
geared for now thanks Allah this form
here ax squared plus BX plus C it's a
mess it's terrible it's really hard to
work with there's are very little that
you can see immediately all these are
important features and so that's why we
rewrite it like this so these guys have
names
good morning this guy here is called
general form in general form thanks this
guy down here is called I'll just put
some bigger lie to you this guy is
called vertex form there's a couple of
names but this is the most hopeful one
here's why the vertex is the bottom or
the top of the parabola maybe destroy
yourself a little parabola shape over
here something like this or something
like this the vertex is where the
parabola turns around so see how this
one turns around right of the origin its
vertex would be the origin or this guy
here turns around at whatever those
coordinates are that would be the vertex
yesterday we were thinking about minimum
values or Maxima those the minimum or
the maximum they happen at the vertex
here's the nice thing about vertex form
just like this tells you the gradient
and the y-intercept right away I can't
click with my left hand this gives you
the vertex right away if you pay
attention to these numbers so let me
just give you an example if I wrote down
say this
I just chose five so let's use a
different number shall we if you looked
at something like this excuse me the
vertex is going to be three comma one
yesterday we're using some software to
help us we used Excel I'm going to point
you to another piece of where we use
this before desmos because we can all
graph this right now and I'll prove to
you that this is the way it is okay so
what we're going to do is just play
around with this guy for a minute so if
we type in y equals this as it is and
you can see you've got the keyboard down
here it's a bit easier than Excel to use
let's just chuck in the characters y
equals and as promised you can see for
this particular version this particular
equation
there's the vertex right there in fact
you can even type in desmos is really
nice it'll take coordinates for you if
you like I was saying three comma not to
come this just 1 3 comma 1 there he is
right there at the vertex ok so when you
see something written in this form this
guy is the x-coordinate and this guy is
the y-coordinate of the vertex
that's enough ok now just be watchful
though just be watchful what are you
coming thanks man
be watchful because the signs kind of
play tricks on you so notice how I've
written this and it's a bit unusual
there's a minus here and a plus here
there's it kind of important so see how
I've got the same - and the same plus
there if we switch around the signs if
we switch around the signs and we'll
play around with this or desmos you get
things that are a little bit different
so for example if this was an X plus 3
instead of an X minus 3 where would you
predict based on what we can see here
where would you predict the vertex would
be if I change the minus 3 into a plus
well what happened it's coming all the
way over here now you can have a look
maybe I'll zoom in a little bit just so
you can see the numbers there you go you
can see the vertex has come all the way
over here it's not over it positive 3
it's over here at negative 3 that's what
funny isn't it so have a look at this
see how 2 plus 9 a - it's the opposite
of that okay so it's admittedly a little
bit confusing but that's why you've got
some technology to help you experiment
with that a little bit so these two
numbers here the 3 and the 1 in this
context will give you the vertex what do
you think this 2 does out the front yeah
yes that's a good way to state it so we
can experiment with this if you've got
something like this on your screen right
now I'll do a handy thing that desmos
can go away let's turn off the internet
there we go I'm going to replace the 2
just with a letter I'm going to just go
with the letter
what can I choose here if it's easy
let's go with the letter A now when you
put in a letter that's not X or Y it
will prompt you hey do you want to add a
slider to muck around with that number
so go ahead hit the blue button this is
the graph 1 X plus 3 all squared plus 1
because a equals 1 at the moment so if I
go ahead and I change a what's what
happens as recur was mentioning
predicting
you can see as I make a bigger this is
ten X plus three squared plus one it
gets narrower narrow narrower I went
from 1 to positive 10 what would you
predict happens if I went to the
opposite direction over here it's a
negative values okay so when I have a go
lo and behold tada when you have
negative values for a you've got a
parabola that's facing yeah we call it
concave down because um I think back to
science and lenses and stuff like that
it's concave that way okay so use desmos
to play around with this but just like
before in fact I'm going to hit the
animate now so you can it'll move
without me talking notice where the
vertex is the vertex is always locked in
place no matter what a is the way we
would say it is the vertex is
independent of a I can change and be
whatever you want the vertex doesn't
depend on a the vertex depends on these
guys see it's endlessly entertaining
isn't it it's yeah we're easily amused
does that make sense
okay so just come back to here if you
haven't written it already this is the x
coordinate this is the y coordinate of
the vertex so now I'm just gonna pause
it so you stop watching it
ah there we go so now I'm gonna label
this two at the front what did we say
how would you burn it I would say it
controls the width and also the
direction is it is that wider is it
narrow is facing up or is it facing down
the one fancy word that encapsulate all
of this is concavity but that's a bit of
a fancy word and we know what with the
direction R and can carry this a bit
technical we don't really need to worry
about it so I think that's a fine
definition for that